have you heard of Andrew yang Burnie a
spot-on tick-tock the increasingly
popular social media app has been
getting more and more political the
platform's young users are taking to
tik-tok to express their political views
promote their favorite candidates and
even react to political news but with 24
million active users in the u.s. experts
are warning that the platform could be
used to spread misinformation ahead of
the 2020 election Tech Talk is just a
platform it looks like a fun video
platform but it is a platform for speech
and so that speech is going to take many
forms video is hard to moderate because
it's just a lot of information it's not
one picture it's not one thing of text
it's visual and it's audio and all of
that is just really really difficult and
time consuming and requires a lot of
human labour so how exactly does tik-tok
work the social network makes it
extremely easy to create and share
so-called video memes whoa all you got
to do is pick an effect record a video
add some music and some text
voila your tik-tok is out in the world
tik-tok is known for its carefree and
catchy content and the company says its
mission is to inspire creativity and
bring joy but some users say they've
noticed that political videos get more
attention than non political videos like
this trump dance post which got more
than half a million views 20 20 20 times
from my Trump video it did start a lot
of argument or debate many users say
they're drawn to tik-tok because it's
easy to gain a large following and
content spreads rapidly you can post one
video and instantly overnight be viral
it's given insane and unexpected
opportunity to a lot of people to
express their opinions because tik-tok
videos can easily go viral there's also
the risk that users will wittingly or
unwittingly share information that's
false and once it spreads it can be
really difficult to stop
for example after President Trump was
impeached by the House of
some users posted a false claim they
shared videos saying the Constitution
says a president impeached by the house
but not convicted by the Senate is
eligible to run for office two more
times
but that paragraph in the video actually
comes from the fact checking websites
Snopes which rates the claim as false
the video which had tens of thousands of
views was removed by tic-tock after the
Wall Street Journal asked about it and
in a statement
tik-tok said it does not permit
misinformation that could cause harm to
our community or the larger public while
this type of content is less common on
tik-tok than on other platforms we take
the issue seriously and remove
deliberate attempts to misrepresent
authoritative sources of news but other
videos are less clear-cut for example
when the hashtag World War three gained
popularity after the u.s. took out
Iranian general Qasem Soleimani many
users posted videos about the draft
which hasn't been active for nearly four
decades while tik-tok doesn't allow
misinformation it makes exceptions for
satire and humor which is why so many of
those videos remain online of course
there's not yet a draft and so like the
though kind of over-the-top teenager
videos of them saying that they don't
want to be drafted or afraid of being
drafted or kind of reacting to it is
that them being political is that them
joking or is that them being really
serious it's really hard to tell in 2016
misinformation and disinformation were
spread on various social media platforms
in various ways including and memes that
appeared to be innocent there's no
evidence that coordinated misinformation
campaigns are infiltrating tik-tok and
the company says it remains vigilant but
with the 20/20 race picking up steam and
millions of Tik Tok videos being
uploaded with political hashtags experts
warn that identifying and flagging
problematic content could be a challenge
for the relatively new platform Tech
Talks at the very nascent stages of
doing this and I think they have their
work cut out for them because they just
might not have the sheer number of
people let alone the rules in place to
kind of attack disinformation
you